joel musgrove team leading 26 start
second appearance is jesse mentioned
against the astros this season 28 year
old
last time out the complete game against
the angels and the most consistent
starter no doubt
rolled weekly to frazier the second
baseman and one away
in the top of the first inning for jill
musgrove
[Applause]
diaz waits on that one pops it up
[Applause]
jake croninworth makes the play
and a couple of quick outs for muskgrove
in the top of the first inning
there's a ball up the middle and bregman
has his first hit against musgrove
got down 0-2 and found a pitch to his
liking for a base hit to center
[Applause]
yard on hits one to right that's going
to be over the head of machado in front
of will myers
not much space between those two
defenders but jordan alvarez found the
perfect spot
see if the astros can cash in with a
little two-out magic and that'll bring
up julie guriel
that ball into right center field
that'll be down for a hit alex bregman
is going to score astros on the board
first one to nothing yielding guerrielle
at rbi single to right center
he got him
great battle with correa but on pitch
number nine musgrove gets his strikeout
and he limits the damage to one run in
the first
robert valdez is the left-hander going
for your houston astros this will mark
his 18th start on the season he is 9-4
that great ground ball percentage makes
it fun to play behind him sitting right
at 99 strikeouts
towards the middle of the diamond 11
miss diaz to his left makes the play and
tatis jr retired 0-1
that's a chopper up the middle
backhanded by diaz just to the left of
second sidearm through the first and
plenty of time to get machado nice play
by letting me diaz
curveball drops in for a beautiful
called third strike fromber often racing
two groundouts in a strikeout to start
this one
kyle tucker stands in against joe
musgrove 02 pitch
as tucker hits one pretty well to right
field all the way back is myers and
he'll watch it go
back to back home runs winning the game
last night and adding to the lead
tonight holy tucker
[Applause]
swing and a miss valdez strikes out
tommy pham back to back strikeout to end
the first and to start the second
lines it the other way that's a fair
ball extra bases for will myers most
likely
brantley will not even try to throw him
out and will standing at second base
with his 19th double of the year
runner in scoring position now with one
away that'll bring up adam frazier
whoa no
oh
wow
fraser says he's okay padres are going
to check on him regardless he's standing
up though he appears to be okay
everybody's asking him is he okay the
helmet was actually knocked off the head
of adam frazier runners on first and
second now austin nola now digging into
the right-hand batters box two and all
in austin nolan that'll draw a visit for
martin maldonado and carlos correa will
join the discussion if you're a pitcher
and you hit a hitter in the head it can
rattle you a little bit maldonado is
doing all the talking there and
gesturing with his right hand rather
emphatically to get his point across to
frobber
that one is going to get down out in
right field meyers got a great read
myers will score padres on the board in
the bottom of the second inning as they
cash in the myers double the base is
loaded and the leadoff hitter coming up
countess the seventh man to come to bat
this inning a couple of slams already
this season
hard hit and through the right side for
a base hit fraser has scored nola's on
his way here's the throw and it's not in
time a two-run single for tatis and the
padres lead three to two andy machado
with a chance now runners on first and
third
that's going to be close and they call
the block joe west called the buck at
first base and another run it's four to
two
valdez is rattled oh he stepped way
towards home plate did you see that
machado and an o2 hole
and hit his foot it did
wow
second hit by pitch this inning were
from valdez plus the ball plus you know
all the hits
comebacker and now you got tucker hung
up between second and third
manny will tag him out and a base
running mistake
oh it changes everything
[Applause]
that'll bring up jordan alvarez
[Applause]
got in on him and he fouls one at the
plate and jordan goes down yeah we
haven't seen we've seen dordon foul some
baseballs off that front leg but we've
never seen him go down like this he is
not happy right now as he punches the
ground
cutting down and in right off that
kneecap that's not good hits one off the
back knee the left knee and he will be
helped off the field
infield shifted against jake cronin
worth lefty deals and way up in it come
on now
when he's been off a lot of the fastball
is missing that way
arm side you can see he's frustrated
two seamer jake doing the limbo
[Applause]
first pitch swinging at a curveball and
will myers comes in to make the catch
go back to first and a tremendous effort
by profile just to keep that one right
there standing ovation
for joe musgrove
well deserved
he leaves with a 4-2 lead in the sixth
inning
no no joe getting the job done
[Applause]
bregman swings at that curve ball skies
it to left center fernando calls for it
and fernando ends the inning
here's johnson out of the bullpen and he
gets his man
so one out tatis junior on first
machado's the batter
hard hit and in the air to deep left
center forget it manny with a no doubter
way up and out of here a two-run shot
and now a four-run lead in the seventh
inning so will myers with jake
cronenworth on first base
that one's hammered to left field forget
it again
way back
off the western metal supply company and
the padres now have an eight to two lead
over the astros
catch for an rbi for fernando and the
padres to put a nine spot up there
fernando launches one to left another
one for the padres upper tank and his
league leading 37th of the season they
have cracked it open ten to two
hard hit the other way manny is there
long throw great scoop
ball game over
what a play by machado and profar to end
it and austin adams with a one two three
ninth inning as the padres even this
series up it's a 10-2 win over the
houston astros